l donc Lenovo Vizag démocratie à Hong Kong
donc Trail Association un visa transpose une
station Lakota Jim assume un résultat vacant un
vieil historique Aladdin Esperance
s'attendait à une telle vague à l'avance nous pensons
que d'accord peut-être que nous pouvons obtenir la moitié des
sièges et nous le considérerons comme un  succès
mais maintenant nous avons comme 90 pour cent des
ventes c'est tellement surprenant
ffft de nerveux et politique j'avoue avoir été
traité de manière appropriée
arriver à être élue conseillère
de mon arrondissement mais en même temps je suis
tellement inquiète pour les frères soeurs
pour l'université Adebisi juste derrière moi
ils sont coulés dans l'actualité télévisée un
manifeste Vautrin elle était en
chaîne démocratie en médiation un laissez-passer  emelita
démocratie avec fox laga a abrogation dealer
principal Avantika co-chef l'exécutif
sur conga kerala area jeepers communauté
comme un
cirque la chimiquement électoral ou approbation ou professionnel
voir concert wh  fr je dois peut être faire des compromis
uniquement au mouvement romantique pour la démocratie
Paul esta el conservateur anonyme et
est tombé Xinhua c'est vraiment une énorme
claque pour Pékin mem CPK on va
te voir moi beurre avait Marion favorisant le
concours comme tu sais qu'il avait besoin d'un
point de vue mais là  c'est vraiment pas grand chose
qu'ils peuvent dire parce que ce
résultat électoral est tellement clair tellement écrasant
avec un taux de participation aussi élevé mais ils vont vraiment
devoir réfléchir à un moyen de
régler ce problème de sortie Victoire
kill de dannegan ma please de voir
polonais a reçu un exécutif sur
oubliez les démocraties pauvres sur Galvin
facile est Ahmet ne me permet pas Lauren même
beaucoup Paloma oncle gay aucune portion de
Santa Barbara massage Claire
ouais encore ils ont baisé Hong Kong et nous
Hong Kong nous n'avons pas baissé l'
opinion n'a pas  balancez ce n'est pas non
, ne leur balançons pas
ouais et écoutez simplement humblement les
voix et habituez-vous à la démocratie le
diable scénique comme vous pouvez l'ajouter